nos dicen se a efe una funcionan tal que
efe - 1 es igual a 3 y f prima de menos
1 es igual a 5 por otra parte se hace la
función definida como jefe x igual a 1
entre x isea
efe efe mayúscula una función definida
como f mayúscula de x igual a efe de x
por gdx y nos preguntan cuánto vale f
prima de menos 1 bien aquí podemos
simplemente aplicar la regla del
producto
vamos a utilizar la regla del producto
de las derivadas para obtener f prima de
x porque f mayúscula prima de x
y es que observa que f mayúscula de x es
igual al producto de estas otras dos
funciones cuando aplicamos la regla del
producto en esto me va a quedar que en
fue mayúscula prima de x es lo mismo que
efe minúscula prima de x la derivada del
primero por el segundo
de x ya esto le sumamos la función que
está en primer lugar tal cual sin
derivar y a esto lo multiplicamos por la
derivada del segundo en especial si
nosotros queremos f prima de menos 1
entonces esto me quedaría de la
siguiente manera
efe mayúscula prima de menos 1 esto es
exactamente lo mismo que y bueno poner
aquí menos 1 efe minúscula prima de
menos 1 x
de -1 ok ya esto sumarle efe de menos 1
multiplica y multiplica a prima de menos
1 la derivada de g evaluada en menos uno
ahora nosotros sabemos cuánto vale la
derivada de efe minúscula evaluada menos
uno bien si lo sabemos es justo lo que
nos dicen aquí efe prima de menos uno es
igual a cinco así que puedo sustituir
esta parte de aquí por menos 5 déjame
ponerlo esto de aquí sabemos que es 5
positivo no menos 55 positivo 5 positivo
y nosotros sabemos cuánto vale
efe de menos uno si también lo sabemos
aquí nos lo dicen
efe de menos uno es igual a tres así que
lo voy a utilizar y lo voy a poner justo
aquí
efe - 1 esto ya podemos quitar y poner
que es igual a 3 a 3
ahora habrá que saber cuánto valen de
menos 1 ig prima de menos 1 pero por
otra parte sabemos que gx es la función
uno entre x así que ya podemos saber
cuánto es g de menos 1 g de menús uno
bueno en lugar de que os voy a poner
menos 1 me va a quedar 1 entre menos uno
lo cual es simplemente menos 1 entonces
ya sabemos cuánto vale g de menos 1 eso
está muy sencillo lo voy a poner con
este color que de menos 1 es menos 1
escribamos lo esto de aquí es menos 1 ok
y por último pero no menos importante
queremos encontrar cuánto valen que
prima de menos 1 así que tenemos que
sacar la derivada de g
x gdx es igual a 1 entre x así que
déjame notarlo por aquí que de x es
igual y en lugar de poner uno entre x
voy a poner x a la menos uno para poder
aplicar la regla de las potencias si
queremos encontrar la derivada de esta
función que tengo aquí bueno si
aplicamos la regla de las potencias este
exponente lo voy a bajar y me va a
quedar menos 1 que multiplican a x
elevado a la menos uno menos uno es
decir a la menos dos y si ahora quiero
encontrar cuánto vale
prima de menos uno bueno esto va a ser
igual a menos uno que multiplica a menos
uno elevado a la menos dos
ahora esto es exactamente lo mismo que
menos uno entre menos uno elevado al
cuadrado al cuadrado y menos un elevado
al cuadrado sólo es uno positivo
entonces todo esto prima de menos uno
nos da de resultado menos uno
así que déjame escribir lo que prima de
-1 me da como resultado en menos 1 y
ahora sí si quiero encontrar cuánto es
efe mayúscula prima de menos 1 bueno
esto va a ser igual a quien a 5 x menos
1 lo cual es menos 5 ok más 3 por menos
1 lo cual es menos 3 entonces esto es
igual a menos 8 y ya puedo poner que es
mayúscula prima de menos 1 es lo mismo
que menos 8 y hemos acabado